life's so short at such glorious images
in the world and such horror as well but
I want to see it all I don't really just
did it well that I talked about
inhabitants in Israel there are zombies
be bold and mighty forces will come to
your aid I believe that about everything
you have to make our lives because life
is tough I have to believe in the power
of life he's a Welsh actor on film stage
and television he's considered to be one
of the world's greatest living actors
and is most well known for his role as
Hannibal Lecter in the Silence of the
land everything you need to find him is
right there those pages since 2016 he
starred in the critically acclaimed HBO
series West world he's Anthony Hopkins
and here's my take on its top ten rules
of success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'm super curious
to figure out which one you guys like
the best also as you're watching the
clips if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well when you write something down
that's much more likely to stick with
you to enjoy
[Music]
do something new you know you got to
make you've got a chancellor in your
comfort zone that's what we all do we
get to a certain age will stay in their
comfort zone Ravel recliners watching
television they in there and we get
certain a jingly recently the interview
I sit around watching television to the
rest of my life because I've done it all
sitting on my laurels it reads it's not
worth it I mean life's so short and such
glorious images in the world and such
horror as well but I want to see it all
so I've moved out of my comfort zone
that's some essential for me otherwise I
may as well die
so I've done it ever broken every rule
in the book and not out of malice or any
having anyone that I'll show you I did
it for to show myself I've showed myself
I looked in America I'll show you one
day that done something completely new I
wrote the music and I feel limitless
once I got started with two magician and
one bunch and Christmas happening once I
got the knack of it it became easier and
then I Jordan Adam would make moments
you know when I was learning the script
and I thought boy this isn't gonna work
I mean how how can I do it but I used to
write notes to myself looking letters to
myself and put them on with that thing
you know it you could do anything you
know anything but face you can move
mountains and uh trust and let go and
all that was a you know I like to just
throw myself into them then they went
the negatives came to my mind I would
but positive possible sound my head you
know maybe I can do it and I I used to
meditate that visualize myself doing it
nice to visualize myself on like a kind
of time visualize myself doing those
sort of having cards and springing them
and and gradually surprising the power
of mind what happened to know your
muscles begin to respond like anything
that may see playing the piano or
driving a car coming through the
relaxation
yes but you did get older you love lives
on w you change he meant was I know
although he has to change and I realized
over the years I've got so many changes
in my life and changes because that make
so much that you don't know with it it
means when I believe this what again I
don't know we live in the past
it just didn't care all the time talk
about an inhabitant thirty Israel
they're like zombies and I can't hang
out with those people I know I can't
spend more than five minutes of actual
actual end because I feel so guilty for
being happy but
because it's a hero night recession too
many years I don't like to speak with us
often big event and somebody in Lausanne
said to me is the big event like this
intention you know we spend so much time
thinking it's resolutely big events the
big red clock will start is now whole
life is magical it is magic because
we're the instruments and all problem is
a technical once you can go through
those problems without avoiding them are
backing off from them because all you
know is like fear you go through it you
go through the problem confronted and go
through it then you have really
Stanislavski called it the plane of
inspiration that takes off and runway
the runway is the technique the runway
after getting on with it the plane will
take off if I'm Tuesday night however it
doesn't quite take off it doesn't matter
you can't stop the plane say well I'll
go back because I don't feel it tonight
you get on with it technically and then
on Wednesday night probably it's going
to take off again as long as still
relaxed but it really is it's kind of
being on automatic pilot and I I think
it's and it comes after the experience
that when you come down and I think I
feel in the happy state of mind now that
my I have 15 years or 20 years of
experience behind me and I think it's
used well and and there's a lot of
positive out of all the young anguish
and the pain and discomfort none would
be good times giving negative done
Olivia said once when I it was directing
calling Blakely in June and take our
crab is in german pick up and he said i
you have to find the middleman and
lately support you mean you should find
the middleman that ease of playing a
character Blakely said I only have until
next week and if you won't do it next
week it'll take you the next the rest of
your life and it's really relaxing and
letting go you know they boosted the
puts women throughout all the digression
the arrogance and the ambition all that
that's all very necessary but there's a
time when one has to let go and I guess
I'm in orbit and I all I have to do is
just assure that it's going to be okay
and do what is required you know keeping
practice keep working and going back to
the state I want to go back to the
theater
and I'm being kind to myself I that's
all I can say ready then the magic
happens
Schofield is right to get on with it
John Dexter told me in New York just get
on with it don't analyze do it once the
most important Bazzi with an actor as
right actor like you should have what's
the most important quality apart from
intelligence I suppose but well I'm
going to be modest oh you know I'm
working out I just go from job to job
and I can I think he is I said a
discipline and commitment to it and all
those American words but yeah yeah I
know what you're doing and and I was
funded that I was tell that to young
actors and welcome and enjoy it stop
thinking this all out just enjoy it if
it doesn't work it doesn't work and you
do something bad it doesn't matter and
you do something which may be good
that's good but don't worry about it
it's all it's all part of life's process
next we must have been one of the most
difficult roles you ever played well
does a nightmare old player I am I got a
phone call in England many years ago and
my agent said is Oliver Stone once I
told you and I said understand what it
won't be frozen happen ixom nice Nixon I
said when will you present looks nice
know what thought is he said President
Nixon eyes he's crazy
I know he must be mad and I phoned me up
and he said um well he said ah I hear
you're a chicken you don't want to do it
I said I don't want to do you a
disservice if I'm coming into London
anyway at the beginning next week so
let's meet anyway even though you're
going to do it it's okay
so he's on my way to the hotel to meet
him and I had that moment of clarity
when I in the middle of Hyde Park and I
thought I can either work for this great
American director I'm a complete idiot
of myself all I can stay safe here in
Britain working for the BBC
go off to Hungary to make a
Dostoyevsky's from someone so boring
mother and you know then stay happy for
the rest of my life don't die of a heart
attack at the end of it but I thought
well I'll just do something that's
really challenging
so I met Oliver Stone for breakfast that
very morning if you have now later and I
said I do it is it great so that we were
and I believe that be bold and mighty
forces will come to your aid and I
believe that about everything you know
so it doesn't do anything that's
conventional when I approached magic I
just showed up I did a lot of
preparation all I have to do is be ready
I guess and that I try to apply it to my
life now and I I just have to get ready
now I just have to do what is asked of
me and and do as much as I can without
driving myself insane because that
there's a negative side of perfectionism
in my nature and I can only speak for
myself it's a negative flaw and this is
very dangerous type and I think one of
the biggest killers is ego and when it's
the negative side of perfectionism when
month starts playing God you know and I
mean literally there is a killer then in
a little part of one's own ego I went to
the movies and I saw Brando and I became
an actor I saw James Dean and I I always
felt I wanted to be like that but I
thought I'm stuck with a funny accent in
this place in Britain and I drove that
hijack hair wax on the road and I'd read
them look homeward angel as about
1920s and on that and I had this taste
for America and I had this taste for
rebellion and the darkness and so this
is what I wanted to do more than
anything and when I came over to America
I made a couple of good films and some
not so good films but I wanted to make a
statement for myself on this one not for
anyone but for myself to prove it to
myself that I had this in me I'm going
to be sending any idea that I had
something so off the wall as wacko
I could put it on screen summer that's
why I don't know if I believe in
anything living I'm a deity but I
believe whatever that thing is that we
talk about essentially is I think it's
just in within us
I mean things of a remarkable things
have happened in my life by just wishing
or asking for something for Durov
healthiest and kin and I don't believe
another Nam and agnostic I guess is it
is anyway you can help me or whatever
and there's something inside us that
will respond I believe I believe that we
you have to make our lives because life
is
stuff I have to believe in the power of
life now okay let's talk about this
movie you're you're a priest then then
you're trying to convince this guy that
doesn't really believe and then all the
sudden you become to this that's right
by the devil you you are a good devil
you are here I mean that I meant the
kind of way other I mean really a bad
guy so good when you turn because your
character is not like that for the first
part of the movie and then all of a
sudden you yeah you're a baby comes much
and then suddenly become very yeah yes
change I don't know why they cast me in
these parts I know I do know but I have
no idea because I don't like that at all
yeah they look just doing that as scary
to me I got a sec me I don't know what
it is I I honestly don't know seriously
people say how do you do that no idea I
just do it like do it like like right
now just look at the camera and make a
scary scary face oh no that's really
creepy just dead in the eyes that's all
yeah don't blink by the nose called
acting I guess yeah I'm not like that
inside I don't
[Music]
ha ha ha I like is good terrific I tell
the world I'm still working in work with
some interesting people and people think
it's you know a dream but there are
problems you know I I pay a few people
to help me and my wife had a friend
called Irwin our ears and sculpt
johnny-on-the-spot
my wife Stella johnny-on-the-spot means
johnny-on-the-spot except this guy is
very on the spot sometimes can't even
find me supposedly my personal assistant
me 19 lots of money it's really shocking
but that's life I guess it may be quite
bizarre introduce you I shall show you
on the spot
[Music]
that's him
that's johnny-on-the-spot he's a lot of
money and his useless useless my cat
Niblo would be a better assistant what
can you do comment more why life's not
perfect no I didn't have to get rid of
em but anyway that's jobs first class
private travel clouds at our rooms all
the women hug you mom said they don't
even know who I am but you know that's
life
it's not all roses in movie business
yeah that was good
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kendricks Bowman
asking to till there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from Anthony Hopkins today that you're
going to apply immediately to your life
or your business what would your
favorite rule and why leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to the lonely bookaneer
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book dear one word and taking that
picture posting to Instagram those
cookies look delicious and they really
really appreciate your support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you can you believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
what has happened in some strange
secured his way on this journey through
life is that I've become more at peace
with myself I suppose we compensate for
our lives for our lakhs if we choose to
because I felt so lacking as a child and
my adolescent years and early adult
years I through anger resentment or
drive or ambition whatever I found my
way somehow I don't actually believe I
did it totally on my own I believe in
some power of life that is in us I'm
afraid to disturb believe in destiny I
believe that if we relax and let go
enough and actually do believe that our
lives are none of our business and open
up then extraordinary things begin to
happen actually is going them to take
what spiritual surrender summers own now
when we title I mean I my my age many
many years go ahead an age of unfairness
Japanese cities we've got to plan your
career I mean that sent me running out
the doorman you call an hour all right
no I wouldn't careful no you make
certain choices you go along and die you
know you you chart the rapids and the
rocks from the shallows on the depths
and sort of wood but you can't really
control your destiny can't like control
things you just have to let go and
follow it